rêvez-vous d'avoir une voiture pas
spécialement non je pense m'en acheter
une pour les vacances prochaines si j'ai
mon bac évidemment est-ce que vous rêvez
d'avoir une
voiture je me fous des voitures est-ce
que vous rêvez d'avoir une voiture ça
oui oui
pourquoi j'aime la voiture non pas du
tout non pourtant c'est très beau les
voitures personnellement c'est pas du
tout un rêve parce que
ça m'ennuie profondément d'avoir une
voiture une voiture est-ce pour vous un
objet utile ou un objet de luxe non
c'est un objet de luxe à notre à notre
âge du moins c'est un objet de luxe
c'est un peu des deux c'est utile et ça
devient du luxe vu les vu les frais non
c'est un objet qui doit être utile si et
utiliser s'il est indispensable circuler
en voiture estce prendre le métro ah oui
c'est mieux que prendre le métro oui et
pourquoi c'est plus pratique c'est c'est
plus agréable pourquoi plus agréable
expliquez-moi bah je pense que si vous
avez pris le métro vers 6h vous devz
vous en rendre compte tout seul quoi bah
ça dépend parce que quand on prend la
ligne 13 c'est mieux de prendre le métro
à Paris en tout cas c'est je prends pas
la voiture parce que d' je suis
parisienne donc je me déplace à pied en
métro pas à vélo mais transport en
commun c'est formidable pensez-vous que
làge 18 ans soit bien choisi pour la
délivrance du permis de conduire oh oui
certainement parce que même même 18 ans
c'est dangereux de confier une voiture
je un jeune déjà 18 ans on n pas on n
pas les plus matur on fait beaucoup coup
de conneries je pense que plusôt ce
serait vraiment bien plus dangereux
parce qu'on a vraiment encore moins
conscience des choses c'est peut-être un
peu trop jeune cette idée de le passer à
16 ans je trouve ça débile moi je me
rends quand même compte que je vais
bientôt avoir 18 ans mais que je ser oui
pas capable de de conduire quoi je ser
pe un danger public c'est trop tôt je
trouve on veut toujours précipiter les
choses dans 18 ans ça va ça va largement
franement moi je TR c'est trop jeune
parce que à 18 ans je pense que on a
trop tendance à vouloir faire de la
vitesse des gens à 18 ans je pense
qu'ils seront peut-être inconscient au
volant que des gens à 20 plus de la
vingtaine je pense ça dépend vraiment de
la maturité des gens et
c'est je pense qu'il y a pas de bonne
réponse honnêtement quelle est la
qualité primordiale pour une voiture
pratique luxueuse ou rapide pratique
pourquoi pratique pour si en sincère
pour son travail rapide et confortable
pratique je pense rapide pour un jeune
et puis pratique et luxueuse pour
quelqu'un plus voiture on s'en fout quoi
c'est du plastique c'est moche quoi
c'est super la en plus quoi donc ouais
non juste juste pratique genre une bonne
voiture